[Musica]
[Applauso]
presumo che ora dovrei cominciare con
una frase d'effetto una citazione colta
o chissà che altro
forse dovrei cominciare mostrando un
grande entusiasmo lomelo mostrandomi
convinta di quello che dico sfruttando
qualche slide con grafici colorati
piuttosto che frasi pungenti
però però deciso di essere sincera con
voi oggi sinceramente il tema per la
prima volta a dio no nomi non mi
convinceva non mi mancavano idee non
fraintendete e avevo però non nessuna di
quelle mi convinceva profondamente
allora come poter trasmettere un
messaggio se non credi in quello che
dici come poter accattivare l'attenzione
della gente se se non si è convinta tu
stessa dell'importanza di ciò che stai
dicendo
avrei potuto parlare delle prime volte
che hanno cambiato e l'umanità di quelle
prime volte che hanno profondamente
mutato il nostro modo di vedere il mondo
che ancora oggi influenza nei nostri
pensieri credo non so 20 luglio 1969 nei
l'altro che il primo uomo sulla luna
sarà un piccolo passo per un uomo un
grande passo per l'umanità
oppure avrei potuto parlare di come per
la prima volta un filosofo ha messo in
dubbio la centralità dell'uomo
nell'universo
oppure ancora prima di come per la prima
volta in una caverna sperduta chissà
dove per la prima volta è stato acceso
un fuoco
la storia dell'uomo è fatta di prime
volte ma ma questo voi già lo sapete
più concretamente avrei potuto parlare
della vita di ogni uomo di tutti noi di
quelle importanti tappe che noi
percorriamo di quelle prime volte che
cambiano comunque fanno parte della
nostra vita
banalmente non so lo sapete il primo
giorno di scuola il primo giorno di
lavoro per chi è più grande e qua la
prima vacanza senza genitori quella se
la ricordano tutti oppure oppure il
primo sorriso il primo pianto del primo
amore lo ricordate vero anzi ve lo
chiedo qui ora per chi vuole non posso
obbligare nessuno però chiudete gli
occhi davanti fatelo vivendo davvero
chiudete gli occhi e adesso provate a
pensare a una prima volta importante
della vostra vita
ok ricordate ogni piccolo particolare
rivivere quelle emozioni e ambientate
tutto voi non potete ma io da qui vedo e
molti di voi stanno sorridendo e questo
perché è la prima volta di qualunque
cosa si tratti è sempre si anticipata da
un po di paura di timore ma è seguita
anche da un'immensa voglia di fare
eccitazione e felicità gioia
certo esistono anche delle prime volte
negative tristi e allora in quel caso
quello che appare sul vostro sorriso sul
nostro sorriso sarà un sorriso velato di
malinconia quanto sarebbe bella una vita
fatta solo di prime volte
e qui
qui mi sono accorta come in realtà il
tema della prima volta mi dava
l'occasione di dire una cosa in cui io
in cui io credo profondamente
avrei potuto dire in altre occasioni ma
qui qui può funzionare
io credo che la nostra vita sia composta
da milioni miliardi infinite prime volte
che ogni cosa che noi facciamo anche la
più semplice la più quotidiana sia una
prima volta unica e irripetibile nella
situazione in cui accade
e se anche così non fosse noi dovremmo
viverla come se fosse tale che mucchio
di stronzate
sì lo state pensando non negate lo fi
belle parole va bene perché di citazioni
però concretamente è una cosa
improponibile e impossibile nella nostra
vita quotidiana nella nostra routine
quando ti svegli sempre alla stessa ora
consumi sempre la medesima colazione del
giorno precedente un sospiro e poi
comincia un'altra frenetica giornata e
quindi esci di casa di corsa e allora
scuola lavoro scuola lavoro torni a casa
vorreste riposare ma in realtà quello
che fai a ingozzarsi di ciò che il frigo
ti può offrire
e diciamocelo non è mai quello che
vorremmo e poi ancora via di nuovo di
corsa studio lavoro o qualsiasi cosa voi
facciate palestra non lo so ognuno lo sa
tutti voi lo sapete quello che fate no
sembra una cosa impossibile nel nostro
paesino quando incontri sempre le stesse
persone alla fermata del bus quando
parli sempre con gli stessi colleghi o
ascolti ogni giorno gli stessi
noiosissimi insegnanti
scusi prof
già quando ormai vivi senza pensarci
vivi in automatico vivi vivi con quella
profonda sensazione di avere di aver già
vissuto quel giorno e allora e allora mi
direte quale prima volta quale prima
volta mi sono messa in un bel problema
immaginate ora ora qui inizia il vero
problema come vado avanti come come
possa convincere voi che hanno i teche
che vi siete ritrovati in quello che ho
detto prima che la nostra vita è fatta
da infinite prime volte
io faccio teatro e faccio parte di una
piccola compagnia liquidi varese ho
recitato un sacco di volte su questo
palco veramente bellissimo e con la mia
compagnia ho avuto modo l'anno scorso di
fare va bene tra gli svariati gli
spettacoli di cui ho avuto la fortuna di
fare parte una straordinaria opera di
pirandello intitolata così è se vi pare
qualcuno la conosce
no bravi complimenti beh ve la consiglio
comunque allora vi cito questo
semplicemente perché penso sia lo
spettacolo di cui ho fatto più repliche
in assoluto va bene una sera una sera
che faceva un freddo tra l'altro tipo su
due giacconi ero qui e stavamo facendo
le prove per la quinta sesta replica un
qualcosa del genere a sé e quella sera
mi sono accorta che mancava qualcosa io
stavo dicendo le battute perfettamente
come come dovevo i movimenti scenici
erano quelli programmati eppure mancava
qualcosa mancava mancava quella magia
che si crea normalmente a teatro
io quella sera stavo dando la
rappresentazione per scontato lo
spettacolo lo stavo dando ma sì io
voglio dire abbiamo già fatto così tante
prove l'abbiamo fatto già così tante
volte
cosa potrà mai cambiare e allora lo
faccio in automatico ma sbagliavo perché
è stata proprio quella sera proprio
mentre ormai dicevo basta basta provare
a cosa serve che ho concretizzato per la
prima volta quanto ogni replica
addirittura ogni prova per quanto sia
formalmente identica a quella precedente
per quanto il palco potrebbe essere lo
stesso i compagni con cui leciti
sicuramente le battute di certo non
vengono cambiate da una settimana
all'altra alcune persone del pubblico
addirittura alla mano le stesse eppure
io vi dico che ogni replica aveva una
sfumatura nuova qualcosa di leggermente
diverso e questo lo si riscontrava nella
reazione del pubblico in quello che io
dentro di me ogni volta provavo in una
delle mie prime elezioni mentre mentre
rosti tuta viola comunque dove siete
seduti poi ora mi è stato detto che un
attore sul palco non deve mai dare nulla
per scontato e deve sempre vivere
l'esperienza del poco con con
grandissimo entusiasmo meravigliandosi
di quello che accade attorno a lui
nonostante sia già stato programmato e
lui vi sia perfettamente consapevole ok
wow meraviglioso meraviglioso ma perché
perché avrei dovuto limitarmi ad
assumere quell'atteggiamento quel modo
di vedere la vita solo sul palco perché
non poteva portarlo nella mia
quotidianità perché voi non dovreste in
fondo già molto prima di me hanno
affermato come il mondo non sia altro
che un grande palcoscenico e ogni
stanchi e viene messo in mostra viene
messo in scena
spettacolo fantastico che lo spettacolo
della vita e noi tutti noi tutti ne
siamo attori
ora come spero per lo meno la mia
affermazione di prima non sembra più
così impossibile così irrealizzabile
vero noi dobbiamo vivere ogni istante
ogni momento
mettendoci tutti noi stessi e questo non
vuol dire che dobbiamo sempre essere
felici perché questo stili che sarebbe
da pazzi
nella nostra rabbia nella nostra
felicità nella nostra tristezza della
nostra disperazione
dobbiamo metterci sempre sempre sempre
sempre noi stessi in quello che facciamo
in ogni istante perché anche se quello
sarà formalmente identico a ciò che
abbiamo fatto il giorno precedente
noi possiamo dargli una sfumatura
diversa noi possiamo far sì che quella
magia che quella fredda serata mancava
lì sul palco esista per sempre nella
nostra vita
sì forse forse la devo utilizzare con
una frase d'effetto una citazione volta
però forse in questo modo se non
riuscite a dirvi qualcosa qui io tengo
profondamente qualcosa in cui credo
qualcosa di vero grazie per l'attenzione
[Applauso]
[Musica]